right here if you can get a quick two
set your defense
because you do have that one timeout if
you can get a stop at the other end to
advance the basketball brooklyn's got
two timeouts holiday has it and duran
comes out on
[Applause]
holiday will drive and look for giannis
[Applause]
giannis
ties the game and becomes the buck's
all-time leading scorer on one stroke
it's only fitting only fitting if you're
going to pass
the great kareem abdul-jabbar
you might as well do it in spectacular
fashion step back three from giannis
and this
the same shot he got on the previous
possession but he was
more in rhythm
with the big fella andre drummond trying
to guard him on the perimeter takes a
look at the opposite clock how much time
do i have left a little right to left
crossover step back
cash
money
rules onto takumbo had 40 and philly on
tuesday has 42 tonight back to back 40
point games his 10th 40-point game of
the season
and amakumbo who basically sealed the
milwaukee win with